foreign
[Music]
will continue to exist but not as a
democracy they want to curtail the
Supreme Court's power they have among
them all the ministers and vice
ministers more indictments than women
and all of the governments they are
anti-eligmentation
and we come to say no we are not we will
not have this
foreign
[Music]
Direction which I think is dangerous to
itself to its democracy it led by by a
prime minister that is facing three
series of corruption
senior members of government were being
convicted already and and as far as the
Palestinian issue some of the senior
personalities within within this
government believing and the annexation
of the West Bank and even make the life
of Palestinians even even well so there
is no much room for optimism considering
all of this
foreign